both cuomo brothers are now out of a job
cnn officially giving chris cuomo the
axe the former anchor now calling out
the network and denying he ever lied to
his boss jeff zucker about how he was
supporting his brother cuomo was
suspended for trying to dig up dirt on
andrew cuomo's sexual harassment
accusers and now we are learning chris
is being hit with another harassment
claim
cnn saying chris didn't give them many
options
chris cuomo one of the most popular
anchors at cnn one of the best-known
names in television news violated
journalistic ethics and norms not once
or twice but many times and that's
ultimately uh what is the result of
today's news there was death by a
thousand cuts where there were just so
many headaches
death by the all nine hundred and ninety
nine hundred thousand of those cuts cnn
never even acknowledged exactly
like what what are they and also
remember that they didn't care about the
policy of what was going on during covid
but they were doing it there was like um
as jim garrity put it today that you
know there were theater critics saying
oh his andrew cuomo's briefings are so
fun they're so interested and and and
that was what led to them uh relaxing
their rule that they couldn't be on
television together doing interviews and
then they were just for fun then it
turns out actually the nursing home is a
huge problem the book was a really
ridiculous thing and at the same time
there's going to be this dispute and
this story is not over because if chris
cuomo is going to try to go after jeff
zucker yeah um and cnn is going to have
to figure out a way to deal with this i
mean obviously the cuomo brothers like
to fight
so
we're in for more entertainment they
could be yeah both going down fighting
greg well you know the both of them are
going to be on my show tonight nice i'll
be watching yeah no i am lying um
i love how stelter was just like
essentially drooling over the leftover
thanksgiving carcass
oh yeah he's really good but he's gone
now everybody i'm available uh and then
there was another bit where he said i
asked uh somebody was on a show has cnn
lost trust on this and it was like of
course they have but it's not cuomo
alone
right it's like it's like asking if
cnn's lost trust how can you say that
when you actually your fingerprints
cnn's fingerprints are all over the
corpse of trust they are i mean the
five-year collusion hoax fine people
hoax drinking bleach every day's worse
than watergate smolette covington um
kavanaugh all of these things build up a
case that cnn's trust is gone i think
this is an opportunity for this network
and i know they listen to me for advice
and some zucker will call me but i'm
often busy this is the time for them to
regain their lost luster by perhaps
cleaning house maybe deciding that the
oppression olympics isn't the way to go
stop pitting people against each other
identities against identities maybe
return to the fact that we're all
americans i know that's not their profit
model
the profit model is that get this group
against this group but if you had you
know if you just finally realized that
americans could really return to just
being americans that would be a good
start do you think katie cnn would do
that would go back to a more straight
news presentation i don't know what
they're going to do
i'm not going to speculate on what
they're going to do but what i do know
is that the war between andrew cuomo and
zucker has completely started andrew
chris cuomo excuse me chris cuomo is not
going to go down alone and he might have
a point
it was a very beneficial relationship
that andrew cuomo was the governor of
governor of new york was a foil against
donald trump and cnn had him on whenever
he wanted because he was the brother of
chris cuomo we all watched it happen we
watched it play out until it was no
longer inappropriate because things
started going downhill for the governor
and now there's all these allegations of
what an in what an internal
investigation found from an outside law
firm which they conveniently left out of
the announcement when they said that he
had been fired they didn't say exactly
what all the problems were but i think
that the executives knew a lot more than
they're willing to let on and there'll
be lots of lawyers involved to find out
and lots of leaking going on about what
was found and what that death by a
thousand cuts because if it really is a
thousand cuts
a lot of people would like to know what
the thousand cuts are
richard look i think uh this was i i
think it's very clear that chris cuomo
didn't tell his boss the entire truth
and what makes this really sad is
because when you're a journalist
especially when you said an anchor chair
there's ethics that you're supposed to
abide by journalism is undergirded by
truth right it's built around the ideals
of transparency accountability and
disclosure when a reporter fails to lead
into those values they continue to sow
the seeds of distrust and mistrust
towards the media and our job is to
shine light into dark places and to
illuminate smoke-filled rooms and cuomo
did the opposite on all of those
okay
one more thing is up next